hello
and thank you for joining us for today's
presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
my name is yama abbasi i'm head of
business and application development
within cell analysis division of
agilent before i introduce our speaker
for today
allow me to share a bit about agilent
and our products for cell analysis
agilent is a trusted leader in life
sciences
clinical research diagnostics and
applied chemical markets
providing laboratories with instruments
services consumables
applications and expertise to enable our
customers to gain
the insights they seek agilent cell
analysis division which now
includes asea seahorse luxel
and also biotech which was
recently acquired by agilent
agilent's rapidly growing cell analysis
portfolio enables deeper more reliable
insight across a variety of cell
analysis applications
where investigators and drug developers
seek to understand
complex cellular environments and
interactions including
sulfate fitness and function
our comprehensive cell analysis tools
are critically important in various
investigative fields such as cancer
inflammation immunology immune oncology
and as you'll find that today
parasitology
i am now delighted to introduce today's
speaker
dr selassie danko dr
danko obtained her phd in biological
sciences and public health at harvard
t.h
kent school of public health her
doctoral research focused on
invasion of erythrocytes by malaria
parasites
the first step in establishment of
malarial infection
her studies identified a key pathway
that
restricts red blood cell invasion
by plasmodium nulci
a malaria parasite that naturally
infects
macaques but has caused outbreaks of
human infection in southeast asia
her findings helped to understand
zoonotic infections
by uh p nolsai
she is currently a postdoctoral fellow
at seattle
children's research institute center for
global infectious disease research
and a recipient of american heart
association
post-doctoral fellowship her work
uncovered a potential mechanism by which
binding of malaria parasites to blood
vessels
can disrupt the blood brain
barrier resulting in brain swelling
her current work aims to investigate the
utility of kinase inhibitors
in repairing a leaky blood-brain barrier
as well as elucidating endothelial
barrier dysfunction
in cerebral malaria before i
hand it over to dr dankwa a couple of
housekeeping notes
there will be a question and answer
period immediately following the talk
and to help us get as many of your
questions as possible we encourage you
to type in your questions
during the presentation also we will
have a lounge session
with the speaker at the end of the
session
and will be also joined by other
colleagues from agilent
please feel free to join us and ask any
additional questions
that you may have and with that i will
hand it over
to dr dankwa
today i'm excited to share with you our
work on a project
that's using kinase inhibitors to better
understand
and to fill your bare regulation both in
healthy conditions and under disease
conditions
we want to be able to come up with ways
to fix endothelial dysfunction in
cerebral malaria but then also in other
diseases
a healthy endothelium is essential for
good health
hopefully for all of us today
endothelium is healthy and as
functioning as it should
in all of the different vessels in which
it is found
in our body so this means that it is
inhibiting coagulation
and allowing the free flow of blood flow
vessels
it is acting as a semi-permeable
membrane to
regulate to properly regulate the
exchange of micro molecules between
blood and tissue
and healthy endothelium should also be
preventing the inappropriate recruitment
of leukocytes
um and so we we want endothelium to be
responding appropriately to various
stimuli
in in a way that protects our bodies
the endothelium becomes even more
important than the disease conditions
where it has to
appropriately respond to various
damaging stimuli
and it's not hard to imagine all the
things that can go wrong
when it doesn't function as it should
and here just some examples of
infectious diseases where endothelial
dysfunction is implicated you have
various viral
bacterial and prosthetic infections and
you can appreciate
from looking at this list that several
of these diseases have significant
morbidity and mortality and not
surprisingly we see that malaya makes
the list
and it's a prosthetic infection that's
caused by
plasmodium parasites that are
transmitted by the bite of an infected
mosquito
plasmodium parasites they enter red
blood cells
and then they grow and replicate inside
of red blood cells
and that sets up um cycles of asexual
replication in the bloodstream
um in the mature forms of these
plasmodium parasites
trophozoites and shizunes as they are
called um
for plasmodium falciparum they bind to
specific receptors on the
endothelial cells so that's depicted
here
you have your president infected red
blood cells um
and there's binding to the endothelium
and then these are em images um also
showing persian infected red blood cells
now this binding to endothelial cells
allows
plasmodium-infected red blood cells to
sequester in microvessels and different
organs in the body they can sequester
in the brain where they can give rise to
cerebral malaria
or in the lungs or in the kidneys and
the guts there's widespread
sequestration in the gut
and so there are lots of opportunities
for endothelial dysfunction
in in malaria and this slide is just
looking more closely at endothelial
dysfunction
in cerebral malaria so there's evidence
of
altered coagulation
you see there's accumulation of fibrin
deposits which is evidence of excessive
thrombin signaling
thrombin is an essential clotting factor
that also triggers
pro-inflammatory signaling and brain
disruptive signaling
and so you have this state of
coedulopathy and there's also evidence
of
of the endothelium being leaky you have
this hypopermeable state
of the endothelium then on the right
hand side
uh various histopathological images from
fatal cases of cerebral malaria you can
see this
vascular leak we can see that from
extravasation
of fibrinogen which is a serum serum
protein into tissue
and there's evidence of fibrin this is
dormant staining
and then down here you can see a vessel
that has
lots of plasmodium-infected red blood
cells all these tiny
dots they show a vessel that's um
engaged with infected red blood cells so
you can very easily appreciate that you
get
microvascular obstruction
with severe malaria
the brain is a particularly vulnerable
site for endothelial dysfunction
we know that severe brain swelling is
strongly associated with death
from cerebral malaria these are mri
images
on the left you can see what a normal
brain looks like and then on the right
is
a brain with severe brain swelling the
brain is constrained by the skull and so
there's nowhere for the
fluid buildup to go and you end up with
compression of the brain stem that's
shown here by these arrows
and the brain stem is the respiratory
center of the brain and so
um kids stop dying stop breathing and
that's
that's sadly how they die um
so we know that um mri images have shown
that
edema that results from breakdown of the
blood being barrier
is implicated in severe brain swelling
but we don't fully understand the
molecular mechanisms that lead to
um to brain swelling and this is
hindering our ability to come up with
um adjective therapy that can help
reverse brain swelling
um and improve survival from cerebral
malaria
they are effective drugs that target the
parasite to kill the parasite
but even with these drugs mortality rate
and cerebral malaria is 15 to 20 percent
and mortality isn't the only big issue
with cerebral malaia even in survivors
you have
um significant neurological sequelae
there was one study that showed that
up to 50 of survivors had various
neurodevelopmental impairments um huena
says that one
one year after recovery from cerebral
malaria
so we need we need adjunct therapy in
addition to the
effective antimalarial drugs we have
because they are not sufficient to
prevent death
this is a slide that just drives home
the point about malaria mortality
it's a slide that shows death rates
per 100 thousand people and you can
appreciate from this map that
sub-saharan africa bears the brunt of
malaria mortality
on the right here are numbers from 2018
this is from the world health
organization malaya report
and in 2018 there were as many as 228
million
clinical cases of malaria
and then excuse me just a little over
400 000 deaths
um and like i said we have we have
effective drugs that kill the parasite
but you still have all of this uh
mortality
and so we need new interventions we need
adjunctive therapy
host targeted therapy that can be
given together with parasite um
targeting drugs to decrease the deaths
from
from malaria this is a map for malaria
mortality
in general but most of the dust from
malaya are from cerebral malaria
and so you can imagine that host targets
are therapeutics
that that repair and they will
dysfunction
and create the stage where the
film can function as it should um could
potentially decrease
death and improve survival from cerebral
malaria but also from other diseases
that share features of endothelial
dysfunction
um and you know like we've shown before
so thrombosis and the state of
endothelial dysfunction
you have thrombosis there's localized or
disseminated coagulation
you have leaky barriers and severe cases
like disease like sexes you have
complete organ failure
and so there's this growing
appreciation that whose targeted
therapeutics can be really important in
diseases like
like cerebral malaria and there are
various host targeted therapeutics
classes of therapeutics that one might
consider
um kinase inhibitors are particularly
attractive because
well there are so many kinases
in humans there are more than 500
protein kinases which are involved in a
wide range of cellular processes
including endothelial bioregulation we
know that there's extensive kinase
involvement
in embedded disruption and bear
restoration
um also kinase inhibitors have
historically been a successful class of
therapeutics they are prominently used
in
um in diseases like cancer and so they
could be efficacious
um just in repair and methylate
dysfunction
and cerebral malaria like i mentioned
but then also other
vascular inflammatory diseases
and there are already some kinase
inhibitors that have been shown to have
a positive effect on the endothelial
barrier
and so these are reports showing
efficacy of bcr-able kinase inhibitors
i should explain bcr able it's a
tyrosine kinase
that's formed during chronic myelogenous
myelogenous leukemia
it's implicated in the pathogenesis of
cml
and so these kinase inhibitors were
developed as um
first line therapy for patients with cml
but then there have been a number of
reports in recent years that have shown
efficacy and decreasing of these
bcr-able kinase inhibitors in decreasing
edema
and endothelial bio dysfunction so
specifically in maternity
and in barcelona and they've been shown
to be effective
in an individual in most various mass
models and then there's this case report
with imatinib
and two of these studies um shown here
showed that imatinib uh
the the the positive effect of imatinib
and
business on the endothelial barrier can
be attributed to these two kinases
or imatinib is able to and then for
business
it's both able to and map 4k
force and then we described it as you
know one head or two head
um mechanism of action for these two
um kinase inhibitors and
these papers provided evidence to show
that
the positive effects of these two kinase
inhibitors on the barrier mediated by
these two kinases
um work together to to inhibit the
formation of actin stress fibers which
is associated with biodisruption
but then they also strengthen focal
adhesions
and focal adhesions are these
macromolecular complexes
depicted here in this very simple
schematic
focal adhesions help to uncover the
endothelial cells to the extracellular
matrix
um so to begin with for our study we are
like why don't we just
treat endothelial cells with bcr-able
kinase inhibitors and see what they do
and so we use the excelligence rtca
system
to monitor integrity
of monolayus of primary human brain
microvascular
endothelial cells it's a mouthful so i'm
just going to
be referring to these cells as hb mixed
with the talk
and so we treated hb mix with three
bcr-abl kinase inhibitors with sutinib
imatinib which i just explained before
and then the saturnine and we
found varying phenotypes um would this
be kinase inhibitors but susannah was
very protective we see
obaya strengthening it enhance the
barrier you see this acute
um phase of breast strengthening which
tapers off a bit with glucitan
and then we're just certain it we see
that it's very disruptive
imatinib did not seem to do much to the
barrier under the conditions tested
and we looked at effects of these kinase
inhibitors both by accelerant assays
and also by immunofluorescence
microscopy
so this is an image that is showing um
the satellite treated cells
and these cells were stained um with
dappy to look at the nuclei vehicle
heroin it's a
molecular marker of endothelial
of adherence junction so it should
circumferentially stain cells
and where the the monolayer has an
entire barrier
and then cells will sustain to look at
actin
and you can appreciate that there are
lots of intracellular gaps that form
between
cells as indicated by these arrows in
intersecting
treated cells and so that match what we
see in excellence assays
and so this was a surprising result to
we were expecting that these three bcr
able kinase inhibitors would do the same
thing and do it
we were designed against the same target
but here we are seeing these diverging
phenotypes
we also wanted to test um these three
bcr-abl kinase inhibitors against
um hb mix that were treated with
thrombin
to better mimic disease conditions and
so in this experimental setup we treat
hb mex with thrombin
um in vitro it's an acute rapid stimul
stimulus and it causes significant
biodisruption
so we allow this to progress for some
time and then we treat with kinase
inhibitors to see
if they will alter throbbing induced
disruption
and similar to what we found in the
resting conditions we see that
with pseudonym when added to fermentated
cells
almost immediately blocks the effects of
thrombin
and the satanic exacerbates thrombin
indeed's bread disruption
and imatinib does not do a whole lot um
it lies on top of
feminine control treated cells
and so from these exogenous assays we
estimated the area under the curve and
we also
tested um increasing concentrations of
each of these three kinase inhibitors to
see how robust these beraphina types
were
and we see that um the sensitivity
continues to strengthen the barrier
in a dorsey-pennant manner the satinib
is progressively biodisruptive
and imatinib and other conditions the
concentrations tested
did not seem to to change
um so to better understand these
diversion phenotypes of bcr-able kinase
inhibitors
we turned to a published data set
so this is data from anastasia said all
from this nature biotechnology paper
and in this paper they looked at the
activity profiles
of more than 100 kinase inhibitors 178
to be exact
so they they acid these 178 kinase
inhibitors and looked
at the activity on 300 recombinant human
kinases
to get different profiles for each of
these kinase inhibitors
and the kinase inhibitors they tested
included pursuit in it and martinez and
saturn and they found that business and
the satanic significantly inhibit
several different kinases so
roughly 60 kinases for um
about 54 for the saturnin
and then imatinib was a bit more
specific with about five kinases
where activity was decreased by
um to to less than 30 percent
and so we can see that these kinase
inhibitors displace significant
polypharmacology
which is a term that refers to the fact
that okay so these kinase inhibitors
were designed against specific targets
but they they hit many different kinases
and here's just a different
representation of this polypharmacology
which we observe for the sutinib and
assessment especially
um so this is a heat map that's showing
all three hundred kinases
um that way acid and anastasia said l
and in this heat map dark brown is um
indicates kinases
that have been significantly inhibited
so there's very little residual activity
of those kinases after treatment with
the three kinase inhibitors
and then on the other hand those
greenish blue color
indicates kinases whose activity is
enhanced so you have some small set
subset of kinases and this activity is
enhanced
with these kinase inhibitors and what
you can appreciate
from this heat map is that the susanne
and the satanic especially inhibit
so many different kinases and what i've
highlighted in this heat map
are able to and map 4k4 which were two
kinases that
i'm thought to be important in mediating
the effect of
assassinating the pseudonym this has
expanded a bit here
um so we can see
from from this data set that um
for suits in it which is bioprotective
significantly inhibits able to but so
does the settlement which is very
disruptive
which makes you question um if abel 2 is
really explaining
the protective activity of the pseudonym
and then down here we have map 4k4
that's also inhibited by basutinib and
assatinet
though with the certain if it's
inhibited to a lesser degree member
suits in it
but even so we are looking at this heat
map and we see that you know poly
pharmacology is probably important of
targets matter
for the effect of these three bcr able
kinase inhibitors
so how do we make sense of all of this
polypharmatology is messy
um it makes it hard to to understand
how these kinase inhibitors are working
um but then in recent years there have
been
various computational tools that have
developed to
that have been developed to help us make
better sense of polypharmacology
and to be able to deconstruct complex
phenotypes like bioregulation
one such tool is kinase regression which
is what we ended up using for the study
so i'll walk you through how kinase
regression works
so it starts with a a small scale
kinase inhibitor screen so you just
screen
cells of interest with 28 kinase
inhibitors
the data from this screen is then fed
into a
machine learning predictive model and so
this model
is built on data from anastasia
so what i described before the activity
profiles of 178 kinase inhibitors
against 300
kinase targets and these 178 kinase
inhibitors
include these kinase inhibitors that
you're screening with so we know
ahead of time where your targets are um
and then so the data from this screen
is used to train this machine learning
model and then this model is able to
predict
kinases that are important for the
phenotype under investigation
and it's also able to predict the
activity of additional kinase inhibitors
which weren't tested in the primary
screen
so kinase regression has been described
before it's been used to
better understand cell migration
cancer metastasis it's been applied in
the malaya field
looking at host regulators
of plasmodium infection of a different
cell type not red blood cells or
hepatocytes
and so it's it's a pretty easy to use
approach
it can be applied to any cellular
phenotype that is
um quantitative and where you can have a
range of phenotypes
um we're treating with these kinase
inhibitors
and so in the next few slides i'll
explain and
show the drag screen we did using these
28 kinase inhibitors to understand
modulation of the endothelial barrier
and so here again we use this
extellogens the excelligence system
and we're looking at monitoring
barrier integrity under refreshed under
resting conditions so
i'm treating hb max with the 20 kinetics
inhibitors and looking over
the next two hours to see how the
barrier did and here i'm showing a graph
that
um has a subset of kinase inhibitors
which we found to be bias strengthening
so in addition to business which is
again shown in purple
there were other kinase inhibitors um
that strongly enhanced the barrier
and then shown here in blue is the
satanic which we saw before was very
disruptive
we also perform the same screen but on
thrombin treated cells
um using a similar setup as just
described before
so cells are first treated with thrombin
it's induced by our disruption
and then we follow up with chinese
inhibitors to see how they
alter germinate indies by disruption
and here we are i'm showing the the same
kinase inhibitors
that were highlighted under resting
conditions
um we see that the kinase inhibitors
that strengthen the bear and the resting
conditions
protect against dominant despair
disruption
either they blunt the effect of thrombin
so you almost immediately see
this um recovery either they do that
and or they they promote faster recovery
of the under the wheel barrier um so
those green kinase inhibitors are k252a
which is our best bearish strengthening
and bioprotective kinase inhibitor it
immediately blunts the effect of
thrombin
and leads to really fast recovery of the
endothelial barrier
on the other hand you have those
brownish greenish kinase inhibitor
that acts a little more slowly but then
eventually leads to faster recovery of
the barrier
so it was interesting to us to see you
know similar phenotypes in my kinetics
of these kinase inhibitors and the
resting
and thrombin activated conditions
we then introduced another yet another
condition
so tnf alpha is an inflammatory cytokine
that's
increased in inflammatory conditions in
malaria
attracts pretty closely with severity so
higher tnf-alpha levels and more severe
cases of malaria
and so we we treat other cells with tnf
alpha and
then um with thrombin
as before and then other kinase
inhibitors and here again we see
very similar phenotypes of these same
bioprotective kinase inhibitors
and so to us this suggested that there
were common pathways that were being
activated
by these kinase inhibitors under each of
these experimental conditions
and the phenotypes we saw with the
barrier protective kinase inhibitors
are similar to what's been described
before for sphingosine 1-phosphate
um so on the left is springer scene 1
for spain
applied to you i believe this is bovine
lung microvascular endothelial cells and
you see that there's a dose-dependent
increase in barrier strengthening
and then on the right is um s1p
applied to german treats it's also a
very similar setup to
alice where you first treat with ramen
and then add smp
and almost you can see there's blunting
of feminine despair disruption
and then faster recovery back to
baseline
and so interestingly sphingosine
1-phosphate um
people tried to develop it as a
therapeutic and it wasn't successful
because of a lot of
adverse side effects um but perhaps i
kind of kinase inhibitors
might do better in vivo
so in addition to accelerogens assays we
also
monitor the effects of the kinase
inhibitors on hvmx via microscopy
and here i'm showing images taken
um at 15 minutes after the addition of
kinase inhibitors to thrombin treated
cells
um so up here and again the cells we're
staying with similar
with mark as i have described before so
deputy to stay in the nuclear weak and
heroin
which should have um peripheral staining
of the end of the muscles and then
insect monolayer and then actin
and up here is a control cells
not treated with thrombin and then um
this panel highlights either orange is
thrombin treated cells where you see
there are lots of intercellular gaps
indicated by these arrows
and then in green and blue are two
examples of
bioprotector kinase inhibitors so k252a
is our strongest bioprotective kinase
inhibitor
we're at 15 minutes and guts have closed
significantly you see some gums but
nothing at
all like the thrombin alone treats
itself and then pkr inhibitor is also
very protective
but not to the same extents as k25 to a
um and there's decrease and gaps is
quantified here on the right
so you see diameter into cells in orange
significant gaps at 15 minutes kt5 to a
significant significant decrease in gaps
heatier inhibitors are you also
observing gps and gaps though not to the
same expense as k25 to a
and then this brownish greenish kinase
inhibitor
is a kinase inhibitor that acts with
slower kinetics
compared to k250 and pkr inhibitor
and then at 19 minutes we see that while
there are still some gaps remaining and
fermentated cell
shown here the eventually no gaps in
k25ta
and pkr inhibitor treated cells as well
as a slower acting
kinase inhibitor so overall we see that
there's really good concordance between
microscopy and exogenous assays
and that you know we've identified
kinase inhibitors that are bioprotective
in the context of filament stimulation
and so here's a family of all the 28
kinase inhibitors
and the bar graph on the right here is
looking at the area under the cave
and we've shown um highlighted these
bioprotective kinase inhibitors as well
as the satanism
and this is where the bc excuse me that
bc are able kindness inhibits us for
the sudden which is very disruptive
imatinib which
seems to be very unneutral under these
conditions and then the sutinib which is
very protective
and so we can see that you know you have
kinase inhibitors at both ends of the
spectrum but then you also have a number
of kinase inhibitors that don't seem to
be doing much to the end of the whole
barrier
and overall we see this differential
modulation of kinase inhibitors
on primary hv max
in addition to the area under the cave
we looked at a different metric to try
and get a sense of
recovery um and for this metric which we
call
50 recovery cell index we basically
estimate uh we we determine the time
point
at which uh thrombin treated cells have
recovered by fifty percent
so going from let's say negative point
eight to negative point four
um and at that time point we we
note the cell index of
hbmegs treated by all the different
kinase inhibitors and that's a 50
recovery cell index and by this
different metric we see
very similar phenotypes the same kinase
inhibitors are bioprotective the same
ones are very disruptive
um there are a couple of differences for
example to
toufer satineb but overall the trend is
very similar
and so just comparing hb megs treated by
the 28 kinase inhibitors and the resting
and thrombin activated conditions really
good
correlation between the two experimental
conditions
and then here's a heat map a different
representation of that but then also
including a tnf alpha
and treated cells so
in this heat map um dark brown is
is very destructive kinase inhibitors
for example the satanic and then up here
is very protective
so again potentially similar pathways
that are being
being activated by these kinase
inhibitors
under different conditions in addition
to hb
mix we also looked at primary human
umbilical vein endothelial cells hebex
and we see again very similar phenotypes
so these are the four bear protective
kinase inhibitors
acting with similar dynamics and my
kinetics in
huvecks as hb max
and so in addition to those four we
looked at
we looked at the whole set of 28 kinase
inhibitors and this table
just summarizes how good of a
correlation we see between
hb max and he works and the resting
conditions so just with thrombin alone
sorry with kinase inhibitors alone and
then kinase inhibitors added to thrombin
treated cells
yeah the take away is really good really
good correlation
and so next you know we have data now
from these kind of dynamics our screens
done under different conditions
we apply that data to the kinase
regression model the kail model
and before i show you what the results
of the modeling
[Music]
what the results were i want to take a
bit of time to explain
how the the r predictor model works
so kyara is able to deconvolve
um targets of chinese inhibitors so that
you
um you're able to identify
kinases that are very important for a
specific phenotype so
how does this deconvolution work and so
here's a very simple schematic
with two kinase inhibitors and um three
host kinases
and so
you have kinase inhibitor a and kinase
inhibits a b
kinase and a method a is known ahead of
time to act on
kinases one and two and kinase inhibitor
b
axon kinases two and three but then
we've done our screen
and we know which of these two kinase
and hepatitis gives us a phenotype and
we know that kinetic energy
gives us a phenotype of interest so then
we can deduce the
um host kinase 3 is responsible for the
phenotype of interest
now from this very simple model with two
candidates and hypotheses and three
hosts kind of so it's very easy to see
what the host kindness is that's
implicated in the phenotype of interest
but when you have lots and lots of
kinase inhibitors
um and many many many human kinases 300
to be precise you need a machine
learning model
to figure this out um which is
why we use the kayak predictive model
and this model predicted that 50 kinases
are important and end of the wheelbarrow
regulation
under each of the different conditions
we tested
and we are heartened to see that able to
was predicted which to us was a good
validation of the approach
and so on the right um there were
various kinases predicted
which have been shown to be
involved in various aspects of
bioregulation
and on the right is just an attempt to
assign each of the kinases to the
unknown
known aspects of bioregulation so you
have contractile mechanisms which able
to
is falls under and then things like
causes of regulation of actin stress
fibers in addition to all these
non-kinases the model
interestingly also predicted as many as
30 kinases that haven't been previously
associated with bioregulation
and this was interesting and exciting to
us
and down here i'm just highlighting
different
cellular pathways in which these
predictor kinases
are implicated so productive kinases
here are in
orange or just brown
and so you have predictor kinases in
wrath pathways critical kinases that
interact with vehicle heroin which isn't
surprising
and in the middle here i'm highlighting
predictive kinases and what we call the
lymphe one hub
then k1 is a kinase that's known to be
involved in
regulation of action stress fibers and
you see that
there are many different kinases that
were predicted in this pathway
and then on the right i'm showing the
two negative regulators csk and mckay
of sac family kinases psych family
kindnesses play diverse roles in cells
but they are also involved in
inannabella by regulation they mediate
both prayer restorative and
biodisruptive pathways
and so we can see that just from a small
screen of 28 kinase inhibitors we have
we are probing vast signaling networks
and
this kindness regression tool um allows
us
sources to do this and helps us make
sense of
of barrier regulation
and so in addition to these predicted
kinases
one thing that the chi our model allowed
us to do was to cluster
um kinase inhibitors by their barrier
phenotype just based on the
50 kinases that were predicted so just
to orient you to what you're seeing here
um each column is
one of the 50 predicted kinases and then
each row is one of the 28 kinase
inhibitors that was used in the screen
and the colors here in the heat map
correspond to
the red cassandra civil activity so this
is data from anastasia
which i have referenced before then dark
brown are kinases whose activity is
significantly inhibited
and then in blue bluish green kinases
whose activity is enhanced by the kinase
inhibitors and we can appreciate from
this clustering that the
heat map analysis that there are roughly
three clusters that form
you have this largely bias strengthening
cluster of kinase inhibitors
the second cluster is mostly kinase
inhibitors other very disruptive
and then this cluster up here is kinase
inhibitors that don't fall into either
category
and on the right um is a heat map
um to summarize the activity of each of
the kinase inhibitors so blue is by uh
kitties inhibitors that are
biostrengthening or very protective
and then in brown is kind of inhibitors
that are destructive
and highlighted here and the red dash
line are just kinases that you can
just see by eye separate out these two
clusters
um so cluster three and cluster two
um and then on the right here the bcr
able kinase inhibitors
um even though does satanic or basutinum
is very protective it ends up falling
into this brain disruptive
cluster so it's not perfect
this analysis it's not able to separate
out a satellite from
compositing it but one thing this this
analysis shows
us is that there are additional very
protective kinase inhibitors
that um seem to have a different
mechanism of action from the bcr-abl
kinase inhibitors
just in terms of the kinases that they
inhibit
on hands which is interesting
um and just looking again more closely
at the three bcr able kinase inhibitors
so the pseudonym
and the activity on the 50 predicted
kinases again we can appreciate the
similarities and the differences
um and just how complex
the activity is in terms of kinases that
are inherited or enhanced
and how it really cannot be explained by
one or two kinases
and so just to come back to this idea of
um
protective kinase inhibitors having a
different mechanism from the pseudonym
um just looking at the shape of these
excellent traces from the seasonably
so early and you can see here that um it
acts
early and acutely in terms of
strengthening the barrier and then that
brash room and activity tapers off
on the other hand you have these three
other kinase inhibitors which we've seen
before
which have sustained protection
this example which is slower acting
but then induces barrier strengthening
very enhancing activity which is
sustained
and so with the predictor kinases
um they were predicted by a model it's a
model we need to go and test and
validate the predictions
um and so that's what we did next we
chose a subset of kinases
and the approach we took was to deplete
the levels of each of these kinases and
hb max
so do knock downs based on shrna
gene silencing so we knocked down each
of these kinases individually
and then um check to see how the
knockdown
hb max would fit in the context of from
then from
in challenge and here we can see that
csk so c terminals are kinase which is
one of the two negative regulators of
slack family kinases when you knock it
down
it's very protective in the context of
thrombin
there are several other kinases that
are very disruptive they exacerbate the
from an induced
bird disruption and then a couple of
kinases that didn't seem to have any
effect
under the conditions tested um
we were very interested in the
phenotypes we observed
in excellence assays um between csk and
what k
so mckay is also known as ctk or chk
um both of these kinases are negative
regulators of slack family kinases
but we see that in these assays when you
knock them down
they have contrasting phenotypes they
have opposing
opposing phenotypes and so we want to
have to look at csk and mod k a bit more
closely
so these are accelerance traces that
match um
the summary bar graph i showed on the
previous slide
it's a csk knockdown cell shown in blue
um they blunt the effects of the brown
disruptive effects of thrombin whereas
matt k knockdown cells and orange
exacerbate
thermal inducer disruption we also
looked at the effects of these knockdown
cells
by microscopy and
in this top row uh
scramble control cells csk knockdown
cells my k-knockdown cells under resting
conditions
and you can already appreciate that they
are different
cellular phenotypes morphology which
we are still investigating and trying to
understand what they mean
um but with thrombin challenge so
looking at 40 minutes after the addition
of thrombin you can see
um large significant gaps that appear in
my k-markton cells
um also some gaps in the control cells
go not as bad as my knot down cells and
then in the csk nocturne cells there are
very few gaps
and so once again microscopy here um
supports what we see in the exergence
assays
and so with this finding of
contrasting phenotypes of csk and
mechanotone cells
we were curious to see how knocking down
these two
kinases would affect the protective
activity of the kinase inhibitors which
we found
in the study to be very protective so
then we undertook the set of experiments
where
we knocked down either cskr or madqueen
as before
and then treated with the bioprotective
kinase inhibitors
so knocking down each of these kinases
is going to be perturbing
signaling pathways um that are
likely involved in um the protective
activity of these kinase inhibitors
um here i'm showing the examples of of
k25 to a and pkr inhibitor what we found
when we knocked down csk and mckay and i
just want
to you to i want to draw your attention
to
um the sustained phase of the activity
of these kind of inhibitors if you
consider that
the activity can be split into you have
the early phase in the late phase
and so looking at these two kinase
inhibitors we see that naked now csk and
mud
significantly decrease sustained um
protection of yeah the protective
activity
we see from these two kinase inhibitors
so in the later
phase of the time course whereas the
early
early protection or early barrier
strengthening does not seem to be
affected
with csk and what he knocked down so we
are still investigating this further we
want to better understand
the protective activity of these kinase
inhibitors as well as
protection that's confirmed when you
knock on one kinase or another
now i just want to summarize what i've
shown in this presentation
we've seen that kinase inhibitors can
either enhance or weaken the endothelial
barrier
bcr-abl kinase inhibitors have divergent
um by your phenotypes fully pharmacology
and of targeted matter they are
important um
to the activity of various kinase
inhibitors on cells
and then kinase regression this
experimental combined experimental
computational approach that we used it
is able to deconvolve complex phenotypes
like bioregulation
and then importantly kinase inhibitors
improved in vitro bio properties and
they are promising candidates
for post-directed adjunctive therapy for
cerebral malaria but even potentially
for other
vascular inflammatory conditions
and to end i need to acknowledge
acknowledge everyone that was involved
in this work so this work was a
collaboration between the smith lab
and the karshansky lab so that's joe and
alexis um
and i work closely with molly who's a
technician in the smith lab and then
also with link who's a computational
biologist and was very involved in the
modeling part of the study
and then lizzie and the kashanski lab
also contributed to this work
thank you for your time
[Music]
okay thank you very much uh dr dankwa
for that uh
excellent excellent presentation um
so now uh we'll
start the question and answer portion of
the webinar if you do have any questions
you like to ask
please do submit them and
we'll be able to get to a few questions
uh
by the end of the hour and if we don't
we'll make sure that we get back to you
and then provide you the the the answer
to those uh to those questions
so um let's uh go ahead and get started
uh
first dr don quad so you mentioned the
excellence
technology uh for those in the audience
that
don't necessarily know excellence
can you shed a little light about how
this assay works number one
in number two what are some of the
benefits
of using this technology for
looking at endothelial barrier function
or disruption
sure so like you probably saw from the
presentation like celegence was central
to all of the work that we did we could
not have done this work without the
extent system
and one thing that was really
advantageous about it was being able to
set up these screens in 96 well format
and the accelerant system is it's very
easy to use
it's the hardware software very
user-friendly and making it really easy
to set up these experiments we just grow
the
the endothelial cells and monolayers the
accelerogen is able to track growth
and one really nice feature of the
system is that you can
um have the the
the instrument you can determine um
what the time interval should be so you
can have a record every hour every
minute every second if you want so it
allows a lot of user control
um and for the sort of assays we did
being able to see
barrier strengthening was really
important
because with biodisruption you know we
have the eye of phase it's very easy to
see
gaps that form between and cells and the
monolayers but the bias strengthening
would have been harder to see via if
they alone
and so with the excellent system we're
able to see subtle changes
in bias strengthening so the system
allowed us to monitor both
various strengthening and breath
disruption and we could see
very dynamic changes in the kids over
the time course that we set up the
experiment
and you know you can put your plate in
the machine and step away
and it does all of the recording for you
and then you come back
um and export the data and you're able
to analyze it in excel
so really easy to use and really
critical for these sorts of experiments
great thank you thank you very much
so in your in vitro experiments
the way your workflow is basically set
up is
either you treat with a kinase inhibitor
and look at strengthening or disruption
or you add thrombin and then add the
kinase inhibitors
and and and look at the the phenotype um
i guess one of the questions here is
that could one would one be able to
actually model endothelial disruption
with
infected red blood cells in vitro and
could
the excellent system be used for that
yes we are extremely interested in those
sets of experiments and we are actually
optimizing them in the lab now um so
there are various stimuli that can be
used via
testing now with infected red blood
cells so just adding those two
monolayers of hvmx
as we did for thrombin so instead of
thumbing we would be adding
infected red blood cells and the
kinetics are different
um infected red blood cells acts with
slower kinetics so the assays would be
um a lot longer so it's really nice to
have like selogen
so that we can you know let the plate go
and monitor
um barrier disruption over a period of
several hours
but then we are also interested in using
um
supernatant that's derived from
um rupture of the mature red blood cells
because that's
how the cycles of replication happen
in veto so trying to better simulate
what happens in vivo where you have your
interred blood cells
um you allow them to rupture and they
release all sorts of damage and factors
and toxins and then taking that
supinator
and adding it to the monolayus of humex
which would be a simplest setup
but also um is mimicking what's
happening in vivo
so there are various infected red blood
cell stimuli that we can use
and we are very interested in this
because with experiments i presented we
are
um a biodisruptive stimulus is thrombin
which is important in cerebral malaria
but we don't actually have any prostate
stimulus so we can
set up these experiments with infected
red blood cells alone or even in
combination with thrombin which is what
we see
um in people yeah that's fascinating
that would be
that's that would be great uh the
you know one one of the observations
from the the graphs that you showed me
was
really this remarkable differences in
the kinetics
not only the fact that some of these
kinase inhibitors were
you know obviously disruptive and the
other ones were uh kind of strengthening
the barrier but also the differences in
the kinetics
uh that that you observed um just
wondering if uh
some of the kinases that you identified
to be
involved for example the csk if you
actually looked at the biochemical
activity
of these kinases at different time
points
to see if if there's any correlation
with what you're observing with the
excellent system
yes those are also experiments that we
are interested in doing
um csk and mckay and they get to
negatively regulate the subfamily
kinases and so when you knock them down
you should
see um these stark family kinases that
are active
so there should be different
phosphorylation marks
um that change on the side family
kinases for example sac
it's where the the family gets its name
from so tracking the activity of sac
and looking at specific phosphosites
using phospho-specific antibodies
and then also looking even further
downstream
at the um activity of
substrates that are regulated by the sf
case
and seeing if um how activity
of um psych family kinases or their
substrates
track with by a strengthening of via
disruption
and you can do various genetic studies
you know double knock
knock downs of dual kinases to see how
they affect bearish strengthening and
bear protection
so we are we are interested in probing
further beneath
um looking downstream further beneath
these kinases that were predicted to
understand
what signaling pathways are being
affected and how that correlates with
strengthening of
our protection fantastic
um i mean obviously the focus of your
work was sort of
on uh sort of edema and then
neurology specifically neuro
neurological edema
but i guess one of the other questions
is whether uh
the the the this could also be applied
to other
kind of uh barriers um like like for
example let's say
epithelial barrier function and or
whether it's no
if if it's known that the
basically the parasite also may impact
those activity of those barriers as well
yeah i think you could use like
celebrants for other type of
um barriers you can certainly i mean i i
i don't imagine that it'll work any
differently with
epithelial cells or other types of of
monolayers of cells
um parasites plasmodium parasites bind
specifically to endothelial cells
and so for our purposes we wouldn't be
interested in testing epithelial cells
but the system is vertical enough that
other cell types would work
fantastic okay and with that uh i think
we are coming close to
the end of the session here so
our uh sincere gratitude to the doc dr
dankwa for sharing a really
remarkable and fantastic work thank you
very much
and as i mentioned we do have uh
basically this lounge session after this
presentation if anyone is interested
we will also be chatting in the lounge
as well if there are any
additional questions so dr tango i
appreciate your time
thank you for a remarkable presentation
happy to be here thank you
thank you